it should come as no surprise that a
film by Ingmar Bergman has been
nominated for Best Picture of the year
in cries and whispers he's explored the
contrasting relationships between
sisters with all its inherent conflict
and guilt and brought another example of
stunning cinema to the screen
on that happy note I bring you to people
who have been awarded with the arrival
of a new baby just the other day here
between feedings is miss Paula Prentiss
the only person who was laughing at that
last film club mr. Richard Benjamin
dick didn't you think Burt's performance
in deliverance was fantastic did you I
did I thought your performance and
deliverance was fantastic I missed the
line we've got to start no we're just
fine darling
last weekend it's amazing isn't it that
you think it's such a fantastic
remarkable experience for you I'm going
to get on to the editing business here
we would like to mention that many an
actor has claimed that his best scenes
were left on the cutting room floor if
this were true some studio janitor
possesses a collection of the greatest
green performances of our time
fortunately for us the person whose job
it is to see that the body of a film is
more important than anybody's ego has
the creative know-how and judgments so
vital to the task of editing the
nominations for best achievement in film
editing our grinev field and Marshall
Lucas for American Graffiti
Ralph Kempelen for the day of the jackal
Jordan Leone da police Bud Smith Evan
Lawton and Norman gay for the Exorcist
Frank P Keller and James Galloway for
Jonathan Livingston Seagull William
Reynolds for the sting the envelope
Oh William Reynolds for the sting
to win one of these when you're a film
editor
it helps enormous ly to have terrific
film to work with in the case of the
sting
we had a an inventive script by David
Ward we had a superlative cast and we
had George Roy hill who directed it
brilliantly so it's to them I owe my
thanks for the terrific material and to
you members of the Academy who
appreciated it and voted this Oscar
thank you very much